TACTICS TO TRY AND BRING IT BACK
UP AGAIN.
KATE?
>>> IT WAS ONE YEAR AGO TODAY
THAT A GUNMAN OPENED FIRE INSIDE
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN UVALDE,
TEXAS.
THE REALITY OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING THERE WAS ALMOST TOO ;
a
UNFOLDED AND THE NEWS CAME OUT.;
19 LITTLE CHILDREN AND TWO OF
THEIR TEACHERS WERE KILLED.;
a
THEIR MURDERS FOREVER ALTERING
THE LIVES OF EVERYONE WHO KNEW ;
a
AND LOVED THEM, AND IT SHATTERED
THEIR COMMUNITY.
TODAY, SO MANY OF THESE FAMILIE;
a
ONE YEAR LATER.
LISTEN TO THIS FROM SOME OF THE
WORK DONE BY OUR COLLEAGUE ;
a
STORY.
>> YOU KNOW, MAYBE LEXI IS GONE
IMMEDIATELY AND THAT'S WHAT ;
a
THEY'VE TAKEN FROM ME.
HAD THEY ENGAGED IMMEDIATELY,
AND MY CHILD WAS DECEASED THEN ;
a
KNOW THAT SHE WASN'T SCARED VER;
LONG, AND NOW I DON'T KNOW IF I;
a
TOOK 30, 40 MINUTES AND THAT'S ;
HARD.
THAT'S HARD TO SIT WITH.;
a
.
ANOTHER FAMILY WITH THE VERY
SAME QUESTIONS SHARING THOSE ;
a
VERY SAME QUESTIONS IS THE ;
HER UNCLE JESSE RIZO JOINS US.;
a
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED MANY TIMES
OVER THE PAST YEAR, AND I KNOW ;
a
THAT YOU AND JACKIE'S FAMILY ;
THIS DAY TO COME AND NOW THAT ;
a
FEELING
WHAT ARE YOU FEELING?
>> IT'S OVERWHELMING, SADNESS, ;
a
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A DAY THAT YOU
REFLECT AND YOU THINK ABOUT THE;
a
CHILDREN AND WHAT JACKIE'S LIKE;
AND ALL YOU CAN DO AT THIS POINT
IS BASICALLY SUPPORT EACH OTHER
ON A DAY LIKE THIS.
THERE'S A DAY, OTHER DAYS YOU
BATTLE AND ASK THE HARD ;
a
QUESTIONS AND YOU WANT THOSE ;
ANSWERS, BUT ON A DAY LIKE THIS;
a
E
F
THE FAMILIES.
WE'VE GROWN TO BE ONE BIG
FAMILY, KATE, AND IF ANYTHING
GOOD CAME OUT OF THIS THAT'S ONE
GOOD THING.
WE ALL LOVE EACH OTHER AND ARE
THERE FOR EACH OTHER AND WE ;
a
.
MINUTE AGO, THAT THE ANSWERS ;
a
HAVE NOT BEEN PROVIDED SO ;
SENSE OF CLOSURE.
YOU CAN LEAN ON FAITH AND YOU
CAN LEAN ON YOUR FRIENDS AND TH;
a
COMMUNITY AND THE PEOPLE THAT ;
REACH OUT FROM ACROSS THE WORLD;
a
LOVE US.
SO WE LEAN ON THAT.
WE COUNT ON THAT, BUT TOMORROW
IS ANOTHER DAY AND TOMORROW THE
SAME QUESTIONS LINGER, TO BE ;
a
.
>> YEAH
ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT WE'RE SHOWING RIGHT BESIDE
YOUR IMAGE HERE IN STUDIO, ;
a
AND REALLY, IN MY MIND NEVER
HAVING KNOWN HER AND FOR ;
a
EVERYONE ELSE, SHE IS KIND OF ;
LITTLE GIRL IN HER FIRST
COMMUNION DRESS, AND THAT'S KIND
OF HOW SHE IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
REMEMBERED BY SO MANY BECAUSE ;
a
THAT BEAUTIFUL LITTLE DRESS WIT;
ON THIS DAY, IS THERE ONE MEMORY
THAT YOU'RE HOLDING ON TO TODAY;
a
OF JACKIE?
THERE ARE MANY.
WE GO TO THE PARK AND WE GO TO ;
a
ANIMAL IN THE WATER, THE FAMILY.
YOU MISS ALL OF THAT.
TO ME, THE MOST -- THE THING ;
a
THAT LEFT THE IMPRESSION WITH M;
WAS AT THE FIRST COMMUNION AT
CHURCH WHERE YOU BASICALLY
IMAGINE WHAT IT'S GOING TO BE ;
a
LIKE THE QUINCEANERA WHEN SHE
TURNS 15 AND THE WEDDING YOU SE;
a
THAT SHE INTERACTED WITH ALL OF
OUR FAMILY, IT'S LIKE SHE
BROUGHT US TOGETHER ONE LAST ;
a
.
ALMOST AS IF SHE KNEW.
THE ENTIRE FAMILY WAS AT MY
BROTHER'S HOUSE WHEN WE ;
a
CELEBRATED THE COMMUNION AT MY ;
BROTHER'S HOUSE.
THAT REALLY -- THE DRESS, THAT ;
a
VEIL ON HER HEAD, THE LITTLE ;
CROWN, YOU KNOW, ON HER HEAD.;
a
.
THE MEMORIES THAT YOU WERE ABLE;
a
TO BUILD.
I'M GLAD, HONESTLY, KATE THAT I
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE -- I'M GLAD ;
a
IN THE PAST.
JACKIE -- JACKIE'S ONLY ONE ;
a
.
ALL THESE CHILDREN, THE
TEACHERS, THEY ALL HAVE THE SAME
AND SIMILAR STORY.
THE LOVE THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO
GIVE TO THE WORLD, REALLY.
YOU LOOK AT THOSE PICTURES AND ;
a
E
THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT'S -- IT'S DEVASTATING, TO BE;
a
THAT IT HAPPENED IN THE ;
COMMUNITY AND THE WORLD, IT'S ;
a
>> CAN I ASK YOU REALLY QUICKLY,
TODAY YOU REMEMBER JACKIE.
EVERY DAY YOU REMEMBER JACKIE,
OF COURSE, BUT TODAY IS THE DAY;
a
YOU GET THROUGH AND TOMORROW TH;
.
THIS IS MAYBE IMPOSSIBLE TO ;
a
STILL DO NOT HAVE THE ANSWERS ;
THAT YOU SO DESERVE, THAT THE ;
a
FAMILIES SO DESERVE.
WHAT HAPPENED MINUTE BY MINUTE
AND WHY IT TOOK SO LONG AND WHO;
a
IT?
>> I THINK A LOT OF TIMES, KATE,
PEOPLE REFUSE TO ACCEPT THE ;
a
FACTS.
THEY REFUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR -- THEIR COMPETENCE, ;
a
BASICALLY, AND THAT INFORMATION;
WILL EVENTUALLY COME OUT IN
LITIGATION THROUGH ATTORNEYS AN;
a
.
IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF TIME, AND
SO AS FAR AS MY COMMUNITY, ;
a
THEY'RE HOPING THAT IF THE
LONGER THAT IT TAKES THAT ;
a
SOMEBODY WILL GO AWAY ALMOST AS;
IF IT NEVER HAPPENED, AND THAT';
a
THE ONLY THING ON EYE TRY TO ;
MAKE SENSE OUT OF THIS OFTEN, ;
a
>> IN OTHER COMMUNITIES THATJUS
>> YEAH
>> IN OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT YOU
HAVE YOU HAVE PEOPLE COME OUT ;
a
UVALDE IT WAS A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT SCENARIO, AND IT'S ;
a
.
ANY SENSE AT ALL.
>> AND I KNOW THAT YOU AND SO ;
a
MANY OTHERS -- HAVE NOT GIVEN UP
AND HAVE SOMEHOW FOUND THE ;
a
DARKNESS OF IT ALL WHICH IS HARD
TO UNDERSTAND ESPECIALLY ON A ;
a
DAY LIKE TODAY, BUT JESSE, THANK
YOU FOR ALWAYS BEING -- FOR ;
a
.
I REAL